hey guys my name is Jess McDonough it's
a 17th of every today and you watching
games but youth here's some stories you
can tell your friends about that's up we
got some killer eyes as a tomb raider
screenshots and that adjective is
actually pretty appropriate since laura
seems to be having a really bad time
venturing through the snowy siberian
wilderness laura is after perfil the
nastiness that happened to her in the
previous game this time around there'll
be a day/night system and dynamic
weather if these screenshots are
anything to go by a lot of that dynamic
weather can be summed up in two snow and
slightly more snow Lara's all rubbed up
this time but she's still finding it
hard to get along with the local
wildlife as illustrated by a bear attack
screenshot you can check out the
great-looking collection of images for
yourself on gamespot 2015's biggest
gaming controversy so far is still
raging as developer ready at dawn
finally broke their silence on
discussing the length of the order 1886
ready at dawn's Andre piscina who
previously said he was done commenting
on rumors about the length of the game
has now said at a Milan press conference
that quote at a normal pace and
difficulty level you can finish the game
in a window between eight and ten hours
he also made the comment that game is
opting to play on hard mode would
require at least 12 hours to play the
order through all these figures have
been calculated by ready at Dawn's
internal teams and with that hopefully
we can put all this length drama to bed
finally if you're psyched for the
upcoming Legend of Zelda for Wii U
you'll be glad to hear that the gay
world is going to be as big as the
system can handle series producer Adrian
Numa told game reactor magazine quote
ever since we made the very first
generation of Legend of Zelda games
we've had as larger world as can be
realized with the hardware so you could
say it was inevitable that we've now
done the same with the new wii u title
hopefully this speaks to the impressive
size of the game world and no
to the underpowered we you an umma went
on to say that while he thinks all Zelda
games are open world since they all
offer huge worlds to explore he
explained what's changed now is that the
hardware has progressed to the point
that you can now explore this vast world
seamlessly the underpinning of the game
hasn't changed let me know down in the
comments if you're excited to play the
new zelda on Wii U and what's your
favorite Zelda games you can have the
games bowl we've got stories on the Last
Guardian and an xbox sale that is it
from me today i'll be back same time
tomorrow with a bunch more news so i
hope to see you then